[Music]
the fierce female stop-motions eight are
working together to pull off a glitzy
heist at new york's met Caleb but how in
the world do they do it well the new
creditors are dealing more clues
starting with Brianna's kept a roll down
3-2 on RiRi is 8-ball the computer
hacker she rigs ball room security
cameras so the rest of that the Eve's
can secretly swap the fellow attendee
and hathaways 150 million dollar
necklace for a worthless fake leaves
every time you do good to start for
somebody we should do it turn it on
Sandra Bullock calls the shots
she's mastermind Debbie ocean the
estranged sister of George Clooney's
deceased character Danny the ex-con is
out on parole after serving a lot of
time how long did it take you to figure
all this out five years eight months and
12 days Mindy Kaling makes the fake
jewels Cate Blanchett is Sandra's number
two Helena bonham-carter
a fashion designer shadowing Anne's
character comedian Aquafina a street con
who sneaks in that's a lot and Sarah
Paulson she's the expert thief churned
suburban mom her job look out here we go
that was a really kick-ass group of
women Brianna
please it's hard because you don't
realize it how often you sing Rihanna
songs just like under your breath Wow
and that happened to me I just kind of
had to cut it off really fast because it
was so inappropriate you know this woman
know James Corden is the insurance
investigator interrogating these
seemingly clueless victim a brother
Danny ocean more convicted felon she was
present on the night of the incident so
so was an secretly annal the robbery
she's seen on the subway with the ladies
who she claims not to know so expect a
twist and maybe some in credit bloopers
we did get to see a gag reel all I can
say is it may
people really happy oh we have been
hiked about this movie for so long or it
seems like forever right but the wait is
nearly over oceans 8 will hit theaters
June 8th
[Music]
[Applause]